hey just finishing up
see you again soon how you doing
all right i guess uh dale here
he went to go hang out my meme oh by the
way he's at my house all weekend so
that's a no-go
okay what do you want to do later movies
putt-putt i was thinking maybe we could
go get a test
what kind of test the pregnancy kind
we're closed but the sign said we're
closed
this can't be happening how sure are you
i'm not sure that's why i want to get
the test
well you don't look pregnant that's not
how it works georgie
i know i'm just freaking out right now
let's just go to the drugstore
right i feel like i'm going to throw up
please don't say that
i think i got it it takes 10 minutes for
the results you want me to go in with
you
to watch me pee on a stick i'm being
supportive right now you could try the
same
i'm pregnant you sure i'm not too heavy
i got it
[Music]
i guess it's time to do what people do
on their wedding night georgie
we're going to be parents we don't do
that anymore oh right
besides my water just broke all over
your bed
dead gummit stop having fun and help
them take care of these babies
when i just got home from my day job and
i don't have 10 minutes to my nut job
that's 10 minutes you could be helping
now go change whatever this one is
[Music]
georgie there's a band called guns and
roses on the phone
really yeah the guitar has hurt his hand
and they want you to fill in
[Music]
tell them i can't i'm a dad now okay
this is a long 10 minutes
[Music]
well i'm not really
we're good oh thank god
what a relief i know
we better stop hugging her you're gonna
need another stick to pee on
i wonder who came up with blue raspberry
raspberries ain't blue
it should be blueberry you think
but blueberries ain't blue either
they're purple
the whole blue food situation in this
country needs some work
so what do you want to do probably
something with our clothes on
no kidding that was scary terrifying i
was afraid i was going to marry you
afraid shaking in my boots and what
exactly would be so terrible about mayor
and me
i didn't say terrible you can be afraid
of things that are great
like what uh
oh roller coasters you're an idiot
roller coaster's a good answer i didn't
say
sharks which is what i thought of first
you're making it worse
how is it worse i didn't say it
roller coasters is a good answer
[Music]
[Music]
then